good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is another
beautiful day here in New York City
happy Thursday everyone hey Claude how
you durn hey Jackson doing good I put on
a fresh t-shirt I don't know if any of
the toasters noticed but in the last
maybe three weeks I've had a rotation of
three sweaters they're actually all
sitting right behind me they're all our
merch and Taylor Swift merch but I've
decided to break out of my shell and put
on tie-dye shirt today that does look
like a new shirt yes it's from the Lucky
Brand and I'm feeling very lucky to wear
it it's from Lucky Brand yeah they sent
us me I have a little partnership coming
up with them that's so nice of them yes
it was very generous I got so many
sweatshirts they knew not to send me
anything I needed to leave the house in
because I'm not leaving right we are
definitely not leaving more on that
later I decided to get like a little
dressed out today because it's been it's
really been fueling my participation on
the show so I'm like the typical Xoom
person I'm wearing a sweater and I'm
wearing no pants I'm just wearing like a
skins bodysuit but I must look so funny
I was like running around getting my
coffee getting my ear pods and like my
husband's just like looking at me like
in this card this senators cardigan with
like nude Spanx but it's fine
you from the chest up look like you're
about to attend the most fancy luncheon
congressional at the penthouse
whatever the White House whatever they
call it you just look like you were
about to sign some bills I mean I would
love to sign some bills the first
actually I would love to sign some bills
and that's actually a great segue into
something that we very much need to talk
about today on this year's show because
Olivia put up an episode of maternity
live this morning where she really
opened up and shared what she's been
going through and she's been in the
hospital for the past week
she has preeclampsia and she will be
there for the foreseeable future
and due to the current virus pandemic
and the laws that are in place not one
person can be with her or visit her
during this time and she is deeply
lonely and worried and just wanting some
right contact the problem is like so
much of Priya
I'm CEO it's like your blood pressure in
your emotional state and you can't let
it rise because then that triggers the
preeclampsia but it's like being so
isolated with no one and then she said
the nurses are so lovely but it's like
it's not her husband and it's not her
family and I kind of and I understand
why like we can't be there because we
are in a pandemic but it just seems so
unfair for her to be there we don't know
how long she's gonna be there most
likely maybe a month I don't know we
don't know how long she's gonna be there
so it seems really unfair me spoke about
this on the show before when Governor
Cuomo had those laws about labor and
delivery partners and there was like a
big uproar from the mom community and to
be honest I didn't really understand
that first but now like seeing Olivia
going through it I totally get it and he
actually reversed those laws because
they are borderline like inhumane like -
yeah a woman go through that alone right
to deliver a baby by herself but it
seems as though like this antepartum
stage of pregnancy and being in the
hospital kind of just slipped through
the cracks and I feel like it's the sort
of thing it makes no sense that she
shouldn't have someone be there with her
Zach was tested for coronavirus when she
was and they both didn't have it sure he
could be tested again if he was gonna go
visit her again it seems like something
that just slipped through the cracks and
like we just need to let the governor
know that this is what's going on that
there are women he doesn't know spending
weeks upon weeks in the hospital
completely alone when you know so much
of their health is dependent on their
emotional well-being and their blood
pressure and just like have one person
be able to stay with them all day to sit
in the hospital bed 24 hours a day 7
days a week completely alone is just
it's not it's not how it's supposed to
be and I understand that these are crazy
times but this exception seems like it
can be made so we've started a petition
to get the governor's attention if any
toasters know Governor Cuomo or working
his office or know his nice fella like
please do what you can to share this
with him because it just seems like
something that should be a no-brainer
but unfortunately it's not if you if you
don't have a direct line to the governor
which is understandable please sign the
petition and share it with anyone who
you think might care we don't know if we
can do anything but we just want to help
it feels really helpless like obviously
not to make it about us but it just
feels so helpless like just too thick
FaceTime Olivia every day like you just
want to help so bad
and you can you can't really even drop
stuff off um I tried to like that food
for her like it's just it's really hard
to watch someone you love go through
that so if you are going through the
same thing or someone you know is just
please share the petition or listen to
Olivia's podcast episode the petition
link is gonna be on our Instagram it's
in the maternity live episode
description and just please share it
because it's important yes it is
important it would make a huge
difference and I'm sure there are so
many other women going through the same
thing and and we have this platform and
this just felt like something that we
can do and we and we should do and that
we want to do because it would make a
really big difference for a lot of women
and I think that's why I put on the
blazer today for that important
announcement I think it's so pertinent
like I don't know if we were gonna make
a change before but now that displays
there's some in the conversation like
things are about to change because like
if Governor Cuomo say it got on his desk
in like there may be for every file they
give a picture of like what it's about
and like he saw this blazer he'd be like
oh my god I'm taking this seriously
it'll be like do I do I know her she one
of my peers yeah that's a colleague for
sure for sure on the floor legislating
bruisers bill
filibuster oh that's what I was gonna
say filibustering nothing must
filibuster so please check it out you
guys sorry to get all serious but some
some situations require that and our
sister is no exception if there's
something we can do to help we are
obviously going to so we need the power
of the toasters now more than ever now
more than ever
okay well also check out maternity Lib
because she's just being so cute and
sweet oh and I'm on the episode we
recorded an interview like two weeks ago
and we're just talking about like Niecy
vibes and of course the Anthony gist of
it all and it's a really cute episode
just about like how we grew up and how
we were growing up in our personalities
and how they changed and like how we
think me see might be because I kind of
think she might be a Jackie I mean of
course you do because I think she's
gonna be a Claudia okay so take it north
that's what everyone thinks okay got it
yeah um no I just think that like I'm
gonna be there for the baby so [ __ ]
much like there's no way she's not gonna
be a Claudia that's what I think oh you
think it's gonna be like nurture over
nature well babies minds are like
sponges so as long as I can like in
checked my vibe Antony see like I think
think it'll work
I know but like if you've seen three
identical strangers some people are who
they are
that's the age-old question nature
versus nurture yes and so those are some
of the really philosophical questions
that we debate here at the morning toast
if you've never if you're a first-time
listener like we are a philosophy show
yes later on we are going to be talking
about one of our favorite celebrities
Aristotle oh yes King Aristotle I have
an announcement oh my god you're finally
gonna give us something
yeah I'm sorry by the way I know that
I'm the most annoying person and I'd
love to parade around my secret projects
but like literally I get in trouble from
certain people like if I say too much
and I'm always getting in trouble but I
have permission today to make a very
special announcement I'm so exciting
regarding my comedy special okay welcome
II know we have a name we have a trailer
and we have a release date the name
Claudia ASHRAE disgraced Queen stunning
the trailer is available to watch
courtesy of Entertainment Tonight
having the exclusive Thank You
Entertainment Tonight I'm feeling very
entertained and the third what did I say
that there was date you will be able to
watch
Claudia ashrae disgraced Queen starting
June 30th these special it's available
for pre-order starting today on Amazon
and then it'll be available on a bunch
of other platforms when it comes out I
will keep you all updated on that
but the pre-order is on iTunes I'm so
excited I mean this is like my dream
come true like the beacon was my dream
and just I mean I do feel that the
beacon but just like with the tour like
I had all these like goals for myself
and obviously like I wanted a special
but I did not think that was a
possibility um but it happened and I
have to give such such such a big thank
you to the production company nacelle
and comedy dynamics that like really
made me feel special like on the day
like it was legit you were there like
the lights the camera the crass the
services we got pizza you got Donuts
like it was the best show ever and we
filmed it in New Jersey so it was like
hometown vibes um and we've just like
been working so hard these last few
months since that show to like edit it
and make it concise and good and I'm
really really really really proud of it
so if you came to the show I think
you're gonna love the specialist a
little bit different if you didn't get a
chance to come to the show here is your
chance and if you get anything negative
to say you could shove it up your hairy
ass there's nothing negative to say
because Claudia that's beautiful
everyone is gonna finally understand
what we've been saying like quoting my
special these last few weeks I'm just
like I'm so excited like I'm so proud of
myself that like I did it and I don't
know I'm just I'm feeling so I mean it's
been killing me like literally killing
me not to say anything and I thought we
would film a special and I could release
it the next day I'm like where's the
link and they're like no it was really
really well done so I'm glad that it
wasn't just like some homegrown VHS it's
legit fancy HQ mix um and I just feel
like I'm just so excited like I'm really
this is the best day of my life like I
can finally say it so I'll post the
trailer on my Instagram and everything
and the cover are sickening I had a
whole photo shoot it's amazing this
lipstick cut now another drug for my
special hopefully understand starting
June 30th god oh yeah there's some guys
we're gonna have so much stuff to work
with like twisty lingo Tut's team of
those movements it's really just it's
what it's what we need like it's what we
need it's what we need right now we need
so much right now we really and truly do
I'm so excited for your special I'm so
excited for like everyone to get to
watch it like backwards/forwards break
the tape and then like we can all just
be quoting it left right and center
because these are just the inflections
that I picked up from seeing the show um
like eight times but once I can just
have it on repeat like the quotes are
gonna be off the chain
ya know it's um it's a very fulfilling
feeling to let it put something I'm
actually like nervous I mean everything
makes me nervous
would you call it like a labor of love I
mean of course like and I'm glad that I
filmed the show this was my second to
last show and like when I started those
shows at Caroline's it was a funny show
but it was so different than when I
turned out to because I got so much
practice I did like 90 shows over the
course of those two years so I just
really feel like everyone seemed like a
finish worked out full comedy show like
that I'm really really proud of so I
hope everyone likes it thank you miss
Weissman it came from
my heart your everyone
sorry spoiler alert okay I'm so excited
for that um and I'm just I'm so excited
it's a good it's a good day um it's a
good day and I'm feeling like I have a
big brain really guess what I did
yesterday you read I read you guys and I
am on a kick I'm definitely gonna read
Jessica Simpson's ex you know why I
think that I've been kind of has it in
her book is huge it's like it's not big
enough once you get into it you never
wanted to end I think what I'm gonna do
next is garroted janetti's book because
it's short I see my god it's snackable
like I can I'm really intimidated by
like textbook size books oh my god it
was a delicious treat yes so it early
like just a chocolate chip cookie of
books so anywho next yeah do it and then
you'll work your way up to see Jessica
Simpson yeah I mean I did read that
Howard Stern book that you told me to
read and that list is the warmest yeah
nothing's bigger than that but when they
break it down it's just like 10 or 15
pages of just one interview it just
makes it easier for me to stomach it's
like I'll do one interview today yeah
but that book was so so long like
Jessica Simpson's is a walk in the park
compared to that yeah but also I liked
with the Howard Stern one was that I
knew which interview was in what chapter
so I could skip like someone I didn't
know like I actually I was gonna skip
Bill Murray but it actually ended up
being hilarious yeah all the ones that
you want to skip like you wind up
learning something right okay without
further ado I see that it might be time
what do you think we're gonna recap Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills later today
um in episode and then to live in fest
ah so Jackie you get him hit him so you
would say that it's time then oh let me
ask my friend uh Rafiki she says you
just done great it's time for the fast
eye stories that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jackie but may I have
the floor again sure you all right do
you need to filibuster I need to
filibuster about something it's actually
really really important to me and it's
something that has severe side effects
maybe even a case of RDH so if I don't
get it off my chest I don't want to end
up diagnosed with our RDH oh thou not me
I don't know honestly like I I really
don't know how to say this but you know
sometimes you just have to say the
things that that you want to say to self
that are uncomfortable so I'm just gonna
say it you guys today's episode is
brought to you by honey we all shop
online a lot but did you know you can
make online shopping even better with
honey honey is the free online shopping
tool that saves you money online honey
automatically finds the best promo codes
they scour the internet and
automatically apply them to your cart
which makes online shopping finally feel
as easy as it's supposed to you could
chop a Target Best Buy Sephora Macy's
eBay Etsy Walmart literally of so many
stores like the stores you don't think
they're gonna and so we can you go to
checkout a little box will drop down
once you install honey and all you have
to do is click apply coupons and then
within a few seconds it scans every
promo code on the internet and then you
just watch the price drop I use a number
Bob all the time Sephora Ulta it's
literally the best thing ever so I think
that I think I actually knew about honey
before they became a sponsor because a
toaster told me about it and I was like
how did I know about this and you just
download it it's so easy like if you
don't know computers it's still so easy
it's so easy they have found over 18
million members two billion dollars in
savings and they support over thirty
thousand stores online and they're more
adding more every day their users love
honey us included and that's why it has
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews on the google chrome store not
using honey is literally passing up free
money it's free to use and installs in
just a few seconds plus it's backed by
PayPal so you know you can trust it get
honey for free at join honey dot-com
slash toast that's join honey dot-com /
toast if you want to get it for free so
make sure to go to join honey calm /
toast I'm obsessed with honey if you
have an online shopping addiction
because you know you're making a lot of
investments um it is just something
that'll just alleviate a little bit of
that pit you know because investing can
can be can be risky it can be risky okay
are you ready for our first story we got
more gothy are you addicted I think that
I am I hope that this is just a
quarantine um
phase because I've been one of those
people who doesn't rely on coffee and I
just like I see how can we go on
vacation like you guys are all like
scouring for coffee it's like a burden
to like drink coffee everyday but now
I'm waking up on Mike where's my coffee
yeah
no it is sort of a burden but the
effects that it has are so worth it
otherwise there's no delineation between
sleeping and being awake wow that's
that's exactly it I don't even feel like
I get this a crazy boost of energy but I
feel like once I have my coffee I can
get to work like that yeah it's a
separation once I have my coffee I'm not
focused on what am I going back to sleep
yeah that's true it creates like a break
it's like the sleep the mornings over
it's time to get to work
yeah first story is the big story of the
day mary-kate Olsen files for divorce
from husband Olivier Sarkozy mary-kate
Olsen has reportedly requested an
emergency order to speed along the
divorce process
amid the corona virus pandemic the
Elizabeth and James designer and twin
sister of Ashley Olsen reportedly signed
a petition to divorce the French banker
on April 17th but due to the current
virus pandemic New York courts haven't
been accepting divorce filings and
except in cases of emergency I did not
know that according to TMZ reports Olsen
says her attorney received an email from
Sarkozy's lawyers stating that she
needed to move out of the couple's NYC
apartment by May 18th
Olsen's asking that's our cozy extend
the deadline to May 30th as she can't
meet the deadline due to the
stay-at-home mandates in the city but
claims he hasn't responded she also
claims he terminated there at least
without her knowledge the documents
reportedly state that the what the one
way Olsen can protect her property is by
filing the divorce petition which would
quote trigger an automatic court order
preventing him from disposing of her
property TMZ also reported that she
requested in the divorce petition that
their prenuptial agreement be enforced
well of course she's probably richer
than him yeah uh I don't know he's a
French banker and isn't his brother the
president what yeah his brother I
thought he was a French filmmaker like
he made art movies Oh lovey a Sarkozy
brother Michael Michael is Nicolas
Sarkozy and Nicolas Sarkozy he was the
president of France but he's not anymore
but he was that's yeah that's something
France is that dine past con Max
McCarron got it Khan okay but who do we
think is richer I mean yes he has a
brother who was president like I don't
know if that necessarily makes you so
rich but their fashion empire is legit
as but they own the row Elizabeth and
James they did the Kohl's legit is stuck
but like the term banker can either mean
like can mean one dollar or one trillion
dollars like it's it's just right it'd
be anything
is he a teller at a local branch or is
he the president of a bank right so I
think the fact that she's insisting that
the prenup be enforced makes it sound as
though she's the bigger earner but I
feel like they both earn ya which
honestly should make a divorce like nice
and easy like if you have something to
protect you're not gonna be going after
someone else's money like if you're both
on equal level levels that's why I feel
like it's turning kind of um rough in
the Jay Cutler Kristin Cavallari divorce
because I feel like there's a huge pay
gap between the two yeah yeah I don't
know at those two made me yeah the the
mary-kate um marriage is just kind of
odd to me
I just they're like an odd pairing if
you've ever seen them she's much older
than her and he's not a yes like the
most handsome man on the planet she's 33
and he's 50 and it was always the odd
couple but they seemed to enjoy each
other's company and now when they're
breaking up it's like of course I knew
they would ever work out
no but they worked out for a long time
they were always sitting courtside
together at the Knicks game and I feel
like when you say 33 and 50 it doesn't
sound so bad but I think maybe when she
was in her 20s it just like felt weirder
no and also like the height difference
makes it more exaggerated like these
like he is one of the tallest people and
she is one of the smallest people and I
think we just assume we like we just
associate mary-kate and Ashley with like
Michelle tanner like they're just always
gonna be children oh my god no not
anymore like I to me mary-kate and
Ashley these days are like age like I
couldn't I can't even leave their 33
like I didn't know what I was gonna
think they were 23 or 63 like they are
just this vague
age they're ageless by romona yeah
they're ageless anyways this is really
crazy I mean I hope she die think I
kicked out of her apartment like that
ain't right um and I hope they can have
a speedy and just trial yeah I didn't
realize divorce courts weren't
proceeding I mean it makes a lot of
sense in New York the eviction courts
have been closed for a while and they're
gonna be on like a four month delay
which is actually kind of nice
for people who have most likely lost
their jobs and are having a hard time
paying their rent so it's like they're
given a little bit of a grace period but
I didn't even think about like if you're
in a tumultuous divorce or even like a
bad scary situation you can't get
divorced yeah speaking of these stay at
home orders did you see the video that
Dave Portnoy posted yesterday about um
the flattening the curb turning into
finding a cure I don't think anyone has
ever made more sense like in my life
yeah I never thought I'd hear you say
that but ya know like oh my I was
sending it to my friends and it's just
like this is just speaking to my soul if
you haven't seen this video you need to
watch it like where is the lie there's
it's it's so crazy what what has
happened and what it's turned into and
like you can't like it's just it I just
felt really seen and heard and I think a
lot of people feel that way yeah and
it's like we are in New York which is
kind of the epicenter one of few
epicenters in the country of the virus
and it's my understanding based on what
I've seen in red is that the curb has
been flattened right right and so like
now the governor of California I think
said that they're gonna continue say at
home orders until we find a cure like
that could take years so we're just done
as people like yeah the human experience
is just it's just done for a few years
until we find a cure Wow what if we
never find what if we never find one big
thinker a big thing I mean literally
just in facts packs I mean anybody who
like says something unpopular about
coronavirus like it's the bravest person
ever especially on Twitter like because
it's weirdly how you feel about
coronavirus has now become like a
political affiliation and it's like
you're throwing yourself into this like
terrible place on Twitter where you're
like we're just gonna get scrutinized
either way for whatever you say like if
you feel like we should stay at home to
the end of the year which everyone has a
right to an opinion you feel that way
like you're crazy
and if
you feel like you think I should go back
to normal like you want to tell people
like it's just now become this like
political where it's like I'm not
getting involved once again like but I
just hate how it's like I mean I see
this once a week on the show like
whatever happened to civil discourse no
it's like no this hotbed of moral
turpentine right and they think that's
why his video is so good because there's
absolutely nothing political about it
like I do not know how this man feels
politically I just know he spit in facts
and making sense yeah he's also like
kind of hot oh yeah for sure the beard
is working when the cue yeah no no I
could see like death these pecks through
the earth the gray sweatshirt totally
okay well um are you ready for our next
story because it was something I read
this morning that I hadn't seen
elsewhere and that took me a little bit
by shock please
Naomi Oh Lindo and Chelsea Meisner are
also leading southern charm
sources say ahead of season seven they
both told production they weren't
returning to the show months ago
southern terms season 7 is going to look
very different for Bravo viewers on
Tuesday founding cast member cabron
Eubanks shocked fans when she announced
on Instagram that she believed believing
the long-running reality show and she
may not be the only one Naomi and
Chelsea also won't be back next season
sources confirmed to people on Wednesday
Naomi dropped a major hint about her
exit telling Cameron on Instagram I'm so
damn proud of you and us at Chelsea
Meisner reps for Bravo and um Naomi and
Chelsea did not respond to people's
requests for comment but a source close
to production confirmed their departures
this is interesting but not surprising
cuz they're on that like eating us here
when we're talking about Cameron how
she's just above it like I feel that way
about Naomi too um and even Chelsea not
that she's not like in the mix with
Austin and I just feel like it's a
different sort of show and these women
like value their personal lives over you
know the platform that the show brings
them in cameron proud a really long
statement yesterday like saying all of
that like she understands like the show
is great and it's really like hard to
walk away from it but she knows that
she's doing the right thing yeah I feel
like Naomi and Cameron are in really
similar situations where their
significant others are not really
interested in the show and that makes it
really hard it definitely puts a strain
when
your significant other like can't show
up to all these events and hang out with
your friends so matul has been like I
think pretty vocal Naomi's been pretty
vocal that matul just like it's not
interested in the show like he's in
medical school like he's busy um so I
feel like she's now choosing her future
with Mutulu over her future as a reality
star and I think that's a really really
good choice I'm in Chelsea I feel like
she's just kind of irrelevant oh my god
no I love her no I like her too but to
the storyline she's just like ancillary
she's like dating that Australian surfer
yeah so because she's not single and
she's not dating anyone remotely in the
mix I think again she's choosing love in
her relationship over being on the show
and I think that's a great choice and I
have a lot of respect for all three
women yeah and you know being a reality
star in like a small town can go one of
two ways like being a reality star in
New York obviously like makes you a
micro celebrity and there's a lot of
benefits to it but I feel like an
old-school city like Charleston there
are a lot more challenges when it comes
to being a reality star and Sydney like
that and it maybe isn't all you know
roses and diamonds in Rose eh
yeah but it should be I know it
definitely should be anyways I'm still
super excited for the season like let me
not forget we have Craig and Shep and
Austin and I think Madison I can honest
in an Austin are still together and you
know what I ship um and Kathryn Kathryn
hopefully Eliza so it's it's kind of
like a new Jenna I think it's they do a
good job on like Vanderpump whirls of
rolling like cast members into the next
season so I'm here for all of these
decisions and I very much look forward
to the next season of southern charm to
things we mentioned yesterday or I did
that I thought Eliza Limehouse was
engaged and upon further investigation
it turns out that she got married oh my
god Mazel Tov and the second thing is
Cameron's statement um I don't know if
it was the reason why she released it
but there was a lot of gossip online on
blogs
you know unfounded Instagram accounts
saying that Cameron was leaving the show
because Jason had like a huge affair and
there was no way that she was gonna be
able to like open up her life on a
reality show and not talk about it I man
in her statement and in a bunch of DM
stir fans she
swore that that wasn't true and I
actually believe her I saw that too um I
believe her like the fact that she even
has to speak on these things is she's
just above it and for that reason why
she's leaving she's out um but that's a
great segue into our next story about
more false rumors because Khloe
Kardashian and Tristan Thompson's
headline is being covered by an ad on
enews because their [ __ ] website sucks
have you ever gone to the E news website
to read an article it's covered in ads
and it [ __ ] sucks and that's why I
never like I can't sometimes they'll you
know they post every story Lincoln bio
so like I sometimes I do the whole song
and dance I want to read the story
covered in ads like who reads this who
can read this anyway second I have I'm
so tough for businesses I got to do what
they got to do just let me get the
headline at least the Kardashian and
Tristan Thompson threatened legal action
over woman's malicious paternity claim
Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson
had fired off a cease and desist letter
to a woman claiming mu a star is a
father of her child a news cousin can
exclusively reveal in a cease and desist
letter sent by the former couple's
attorney Marty singer on Wednesday May
13th Kimberly Alexander is asked to
quote immediately stop defaming them
with malicious defamatory lies and
specious fabrications regarding a
paternity claim that surfaced online um
I didn't even know about this story but
also Chloe it took to Twitter to let
everyone know that she is not pregnant
that these rumors are unfounded in like
everyone needs to step the [ __ ] off
right well her Twitter thread was like
the reason why she was trending on
Twitter yesterday is not because she was
pregnant but people were like the
hypocrisy look what she did to Jordan
now she's having sex with Tristan again
they're having another child they
obviously didn't watch the most recent
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians but so she was like look at
all this hate I'm getting and lives
being spread just because of a rumor
that I might be pregnant like you guys
are [ __ ] crazy like leave me alone
and I loved that but now this is like a
weird twist in the story I don't know
how claiming that someone is your
father's child is necessary necessarily
like defamatory because there's a
possibility that it could be true right
but if it's not true then it's lies and
you're putting out lies and you're
making it seem like like Tristan as we
know has been working on his
relationship with Chloe it seems like he
only has
eyes for her now and if it turns out
that he was sleeping with another woman
that would like go against what he's
been trying to do so I there's one easy
way to find out and um hopefully they
will right well I happen to know that it
is extremely hard to get ruled in your
favor in the court of law when it comes
to libelous and defamatory information
true that's me I've tried
so honestly like this seems like a fake
lawsuit um because there's really
nothing that they can do you're a public
figure and that means that people can
say [ __ ] about you even if it's not true
no I mean this is like very clear-cut
he's either the father or not the father
and so she's saying that he's the father
and he's not that is a lie and that is
defamatory maybe they had sex and maybe
he's not even the father but like it's
it's it's not out of the question that
Tristan Thompson could have gotten
another woman pregnant no it's not but
he's saying that he didn't and if he
didn't then this is a defamatory lie
therefore lawsuit I just don't think
like it I don't think a judge would ever
find this to be defamation if it turns
out he's not the father it's defamation
no yes it's eyes on his name no totally
but when you're a public figure you're
not protected like that like in the
court and the justice system yes you are
that's wouldn't you have a defaming
lawsuit it's like someone that's famous
and you're defaming them yeah but it's
like borderline impossible to ever get
that judgment in some situations where
it's like subjective but this is very
like fact sordin or not facts I've only
heard a similar creature never actually
getting a judgment in her favor rebel
Wilson and then it got overturned I feel
like I've heard of tons of celebrities
like they see magazines when like the
magazine will say they're like a drug
addict and they're not like oh also
Katie Holmes one one one time that one
is I think she's Sue Star magazine yeah
so I'm glad that Tristan and Chloe are
taking action like they have enough [ __ ]
to deal with without false rumors I
don't know it seems kind of sad maybe
this girl is just like living in her own
world where she was immaculately
conceived by dressing Tom
like now Khloe Kardashian and her fancy
lawyers are coming after this girl I
mean I don't know this girl she gave
these gave paperwork to a tabloid site
from a genetics place of like that's
suggesting that Tristan is the father of
his child I'm sorry you never said that
oh I'm sorry
tabloid site the gossip of the city
published copies of alleged paperwork
from lb Genetics a facility specializing
in fraternity and family relationship
DNA testing services that suggested
tristan took the paternity test in
January 2020 that same report featured
screenshots of text messages allegedly
sent by Tristan to Kimberly as well as
copies of emails that Kimberly
purportedly received from her former
attorney Lisa bloom I'm very sorry like
I literally thought this woman was just
like going on Instagram story isn't
saying that Tristan got her pregnant I
didn't realize there was paperwork from
a DNA lab involved honestly sounds like
she's a lot of compelling evidence I
just feel like if it were true like
Chloe would just be silent right and
it's like why is this Chloe's problem
it's not they're not together as far as
I know and like her ex man or whatever
like [ __ ] around and getting himself
into some sort of trouble is really not
her business
no but they they're quarantined together
right and their family and they're he's
in her life forever
terrible yeah
but speaking of other Kardashian
pregnancy rumors Kourtney Kardashian is
shutting down a fan who said that she's
pregnant she said this is the shape of
my body Kourtney Kardashian shut down a
fan who assumes she's pregnant thanks to
a bikini photo that the reality star
posted to Instagram on Wednesday she
posted a slideshow of photos of herself
lounging around in a bikini and one fan
commented she's pregnant and Kourtney
replied this is me when I have a few
extra pounds on and I actually love it
I've given birth three amazing times and
this is the shape of my body I mean if
you saw that picture like the fact that
anyone can have anything to say like if
I ever looked like that like and like no
one in the [ __ ] world would think I
was pregnant like I look pregnant now
like honestly I would have never chosen
this story it's just a really slow news
day because like Instagram comments to
me like are not news also like people
comment like [ __ ] like this on my
Instagram all the time and like
not like whatever I choose to respond
like not that I'm Kourtney Kardashian
but like it's just like who gives a [ __ ]
obviously she's like no and you know by
liking snacks this is like quite like
she's just responding to a troll like I
hate when celebrities do this like just
to make a news story cuz she knew that
it was going to and it's like you know
many comments she gets like she would
have had to go searching for that
comment like she gets literally hundreds
of thousands especially bikini photos
like the content is just highly engaged
and I don't even know how she would go
about finding this message because if
you open your comments and you're
Kourtney Kardashian like the one that
you saw is gone a millisecond later
because 30 new ones just came in right
like this sound maybe was planted
totally just so she could have like an
empowering response you know totally I
know we sound like conspiracy theories
but like I feel like this is definitely
a possibility that's like not even like
a big deal if it's a celebrity were to
do that like that seems like PR like 101
just like an easy way to get some good
press clap-clap back at at roll oh god
okay are you ready for a fifth and final
story it's a little bit this no no mmm
sad okay I'm ready um it's a little
Sussex news because Prince Harry is
feeling quote rudderless without friends
or a job in LA the Duke of Sussex is
feeling down since he's fled Canada with
his wife Maggie Markel and their
one-year-old son Archie for sunny
California a source told Vanity Fair
quote he has a lot of friends in the
military community in the UK and of
course he misses them this is a very
strange time for us all but I think
Harry is missing having a structure to
his life right now this sort of said the
Sussex is are living in an 18 million
dollar Beverly Hills mansion owned by
media mogul Tyler Perry interesting
factoid once yeah he doesn't have
friends in LA like Megan and he doesn't
have a job so at the moment he's a bit
rudderless but it won't always be like
this and he knows that honestly in
thinking about it like yeah he's
definitely very sad like obviously he
uprooted his life and took this big leap
of faith because of what him and Megan
were gonna build together but like all
building plans are on pause and he's
just like in this unknown town
um where he has no friends and he has no
family injures house yeah and like I'm
sure all of the Windsors are like in the
queue together in a palace and he's
probably just feeling quote rudderless
you know what honestly my eyes have been
open to like the media's
you know tactics when it comes to um
Harry and Megan and to be honest his
article seems like really obviously like
heavy-handed it's like Megan is the
villain who brought them to LA and had
are you sad and lonely it's like we're
all sad and lonely we're all [ __ ]
quarantined where's my article I'm
feeling Douglas yeah maybe that's how
they wanted to be portrayed but I don't
think this is a Megan thing like this is
a coronavirus thing this is just like
another man is home and feeling sad so
we're supposed to feel bad for a prince
living in an 18 million dollar house
said he didn't even have to pay for with
his beautiful wife and brand-new newborn
baby neither of them have to work for a
living and they don't even have to pay
rent sorry I'm hard pressed to feel bad
for him no we don't have to feel bad we
just have to report on it because I
needed a fifth story okay that I
understand
yeah honestly this one was just like I
was looking for stories for so long
today
you can't [ __ ] put food on the table
for the families I just got laid off
shut the [ __ ] up Harry
yeah we can still okay well he didn't
say anything like a source said to about
anything but yeah oh these sources
everything such [ __ ] I'm done with
the media John I tell you've done yeah I
mean same so those were the best night
stories that you needed to know and now
you know I'm here Lee you barely made it
to that you barely needed to know you
didn't need to know about Mary Kay and
you didn't need to know about southern
charm I feel I want to jump into the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills recap
which is brought to you by Robo killer
you know what's a total buzzkill on your
mood spam calls they totally invade your
space and are super annoying they're
like the last thing you want to deal
with we've teamed up with Robo killer to
give you guys a solution to the growing
spam call problem Robo killer is the app
that stops
spam calls for good they have over a
million spam phone numbers on their
block list and they're adding more
spammers by the minute in the month of
February alone Robo killed or blocked
Robo killer blocked over 70
million spam calls we both recently
downloaded it on our phones and we are
loving it I didn't even remember that I
downloaded it just because I stopped
getting spam quick phone calls and it's
like my life went back to normal no like
the amount of spam phone calls I was
getting like I have no friends I have no
one who actually calls me like if my
phone's ringing you can bet your ass it
was spam with that with Robo killer now
I just get no phone calls and you know
what the spam is smart because they'll
give you a phone number that's like a
replica of your phone number but like
two digits off yeah and so you're like
oh is this my family my phone number
family person calling me we can't even
tell you how many spam calls we used to
get and text messages now we're living
the spam free life and getting sweet
revenge in the process they have
pre-recorded answer box that will mess
with the spam callers who are calling
you it's absolutely hilarious they're
like spam fighting assistants our
personal favorites are the jellyfish
sting and the southern cat lady if you
don't want spammers cramping your style
get robo killer head to robo killer calm
on your mobile device now to download
the new app and new users can get robo
killer free for seven days get out there
and stop those spammers again that's
Robo our OBO killer calm okay Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills we've
wrapped up the episode at Denise's event
I was under the impression based on a
lot of people I follow on Twitter that
tonight was I mean last night was gonna
be the episode where we see Denise
bravo Bravo [ __ ] Bravo I don't
care remember because she's wearing that
outfit but apparently now it's happening
next week Oh interesting
I feel like that would have happened
when we're talking about actually
something like salacious not just some
tit for tat about like you you're
talking too much no you're talking too
much there were so many fights going on
and I just think we should take it like
person by person because to me the most
egregious fight we spoke about this last
week Kyle was being like a little nuts
and to be honest that translated into
this week too like she just like has a
gripe and I and I can literally cannot
put my finger on it and neither can any
of the women and that's what they're
fighting about so I saw her tweet she
was tweeting a lot last night and she
said when she said everyone else here is
being fake at the table basically she's
claiming that like there were other
people in the group who had said
something about jury glam and how it was
annoying and then at the table they were
quiet and so she assumes that that
that's them being fake but like you can
have an opinion about something and not
like share it with the view
think something about someone and just
not staged them because it's not like
you need to start a fight with them
about it just you have a difference of
opinion or like a different way of doing
things but that doesn't mean you need to
air it out all the time and that was
like Kyle's whole thing like saying
opinions and try to start fights on them
when it was just like weird that she
even thought that like why did she care
that Denis had a [ __ ] ice sculpture
like and that Denis now does glam and
not that even Denis needed an excuse but
she's like most the time I come from
work and I get full hair and glam I
didn't know she was on a soap opera at
ten episodes a week but it's like why do
you care first of all second of all she
that she has a reason she's very chill
she hasn't changed at all
no like even for her backyard party like
she was wearing jeans in a sweater like
okay so she had her makeup done but that
doesn't mean anything also like everyone
has grown up from season to season like
even Eric endure eat like they've always
brought the looks but the level that
they bring now is completely different
from what they started as and as to
repointed out no one is more emblematic
of this than Teddy yeah I loved that
montage with her side part yes very
important and it's like Beverly Hills
women have always been like that's their
thing like they are the glamour like
they bring the looks like every outing
is like plan to a tee like they I think
they even coordinate their color schemes
on trips like and the viewers appreciate
that we don't get that from other shows
like New York New Jersey like the styles
are just not it and like Kyle's been on
the show since season one does she not
realize that that's what so many people
love about her own show yeah so Kyle's
whole vibe for the entire episode was
just like having weird opinions and then
sharing them trying to start fights when
it was just weird that she had those
opinions in the first place but to me
the most egregious of the fights at the
dinner was that between Sutton and Dori
because I found myself really
disagreeing with jury when I've recently
become like the conductor of the jury
train because not only did she retell
history factually incorrectly like I
think first of all Sutton is so
well-mannered like she would never flip
out and in an event she never say I'm
gonna freak the [ __ ] out she said I'm
going to flip and she literally said it
so quietly they needed subtitles she was
way behind Lisa and obviously it didn't
turn out to be anything I need more
information on this Joey Maloof
situation but like I don't know it was
so not a big deal it really could
never been brought up again maybe later
on to discuss the glam app thing because
I have a lot of questions but like to
read was just really like gunning her
but Sutton does not have what it takes
to be in this group like the second
somebody's decimeter with the crying at
the dinner yes she's very overwhelmed
like a ninja once she started crying she
couldn't stop because then I think she
was sinking like oh my god like this
isn't like this isn't going my way I'm
not like I now I'm just crying over
nothing and then she was just crying
more and like she couldn't help herself
um and while yes I'm always team to read
and like jury wasn't wrong like she was
freaking out over something that like
wasn't important and Slee said that
whenever like Sutton is harmless like
cereal and kept being like dropped the
mouse I was like yes like literally it's
just leave her alone she's she's sitting
there crying there's nothing else that
you need to say yeah one thing I was
really glad about because I love Lisa
Rinna but I thought she was so wrong
last week and comparing that Kyle didn't
take Kyle obviously doesn't blindly
loyal up blindly defend her friends
because she didn't defend me against Kim
Richards it's like first of all that's
her sister so to compare the two is just
completely unfair and second of all Kyle
actually did defend you against a sister
part of the reason why her relationship
or their sister has been so strained so
I just think that bothered me so much it
was just like Lisa I wanted me to get
involved and I was really glad that when
they met at Erika's Clubhouse which is
like the cutest place ever I was so glad
that Lisa was the one who like
apologized because she was totally wrong
yeah I'm glad that they squashed out
like I don't need to see Kyle arguing
with everyone but there are a few key
fights and I think it's like really this
Kyle jury Teddy situation that is weird
that like seems to keep popping up but I
like last night's episode Denise
Richards just I've always loved her as
the cast member but just she completely
won me over because it's like when she's
back into a corner like she's gonna
start [ __ ] swinging like don't start
with her everyone acts like she's sunnis
and shias she's so that and she's like
I'm [ __ ] Denise Richards like she
would never brag but like she I think
everyone didn't need that reminder like
call her a ragamuffin one more time
she's [ __ ] Denise Richards
she's been on every magazine cover but
then I google cuz I'm like what magazine
cover is like cuz it was every no me l
Cosmo obviously Playboy she cute like
everything under the Sun and I think the
women need a reminder of that
agree like the way that they were just
speaking so derogatory turns towards her
like she's lesser than the group when
they're all equals and if anyone's
better than anyone it's the only actual
famous person Denise yeah and not only
is she famous which can get you like
kind of far in this group but she is so
spot-on about most things it's not like
she's delusional it's not like she's
hard to get along with like she's so
down-to-earth and affable and everybody
loves her and if you want to get into an
argument with her you better gird your
loins because you might lose yet if and
based on what we know about the rest of
the season it feels like all the women
kind of turn on her and usually I'm on
the side of the masses like if one
person's getting but I feel like I'm
gonna be on Denise aside right now I'm
firmly on Denise aside but so we're all
the women like jury even Denise have a
really good friendship and also Denise
is in this position right now because
she's backing up to read for like why do
you care about this Kyle right and so
the relationship that you just pointed
out between Teddy Kyle and to read is
really reminding me of last season with
Lisa Kyle and Dury where it's like Lisa
Lisa is the Jo Rita now do you know any
me and it's like Teddy's the fresh new
hop thing whereas like that was what
Doreen was and Kyle became Lisa
Vanderpump like Oh like she's being
pushed out of the friendship no I think
when it was through when it was Lisa
Derrida and Kyle they were both fighting
over at Lisa's friendship now to read is
like using Teddy and Kyle's friendship
to like make an example of the fact that
Kyle has a double standard for all of
the women like Kai noting Kyle says can
ring true because it doesn't apply to
Teddy and what my favorite moment I
can't believe we just closed right over
it we were talking about Denise when
Kyle was like I kind of shopping my
movies like we should take a trip to
Santa Barbara and genichi was like I'm
working on 10 shows at two kids I take
care of a special-needs daughter and
it's like yeah how busy yeah I mean I
just don't know like I I'm not gonna
judge their schedules because I don't
know what goes into putting on a movie
or being in a TV show but I yeah I'm
glad when some of the busier ones are
like we're all busy you know it's just
like being busy it's not a personality
trait no when being busy is just it's
not an excuse when you're with
a group of busy successful ambitious
women yeah totally and by the way Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills is at the
top of your shove your call sheet
because it's really for most of these
women the thing that got them everything
else so you want to prioritize that you
want to make time for filming and trips
and dinners etc because most of the rest
wouldn't exist without it you said it it
was a great episode and you know what I
love her but you know it's a good really
good episode of housewives when there's
so much drama at a dinner and one of
your favorites isn't even there Garcelle
oh I know I'm loving Garcelle because
like I I just need her to be herself
like some of the women like they must be
involved in the drama in order to be
interesting and they know that and and
so they do that but Garcelle like I will
watch her kids birthday party like I
just and what was frustrating and we
said this last week is like they're
really like moving along very quickly
because we got like three separate
flashbacks about dirty talking about her
restaurant and it was from like three
different instances that we didn't get
to see that looked like prime filming
situations like Gunners and to read and
Garcelle look like they're in some sort
of furniture store and it's frustrating
that we're not getting like all of those
scenes that they shot but I'm sure maybe
they're just sparing us some mundane
acting I think it's it's clear that the
second half of the season had way more
stuff in it and it does feel like
they're rushing like all that restaurant
stuff felt like it came so out of left
field and they didn't even show us the
conversation Denise had with her older
daughter who said she heard about
threesomes and by no means did I really
care to see that conversation but it's
something they normally would have shown
us yeah but I'm grateful because I did
not need to see that conversation yes
aim um I just love Erica like she's just
the coolest baddest [ __ ] alive and
she's really not even a part of a lot of
this drama but to me I just want to hear
from her like I need to know what she
knows I just I just need to know what
she thinks yes she should really like
narrate the show yeah like do they still
write blog posts no so Kyle was tweeting
yesterday and someone tweeted at her
like so obvious you're trying to do
damage control cuz you were tweeting so
much as episode and she's like actually
they asked us to tweet instead of blog
now Oh interesting I actually went to
the
the woman's Twitter because I wanted to
see what um what they had to say but
Kyle was really the only one like
sharing information yeah she tweeted a
lot um and she's been my like one of my
favorites but there's something going on
there's something going on it's not like
the end of Kyle or anything like that
but it's just like there's a feeling
there and we need to get to the bottom
of it that's what we shall do next week
on Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
totally new york tonight i started
season two of dead to me i think i'm on
episode four and it's so good it's it's
just enjoyable i mean it's really it's
just so annoying like when she no but
you sitting in the closet and crying and
like opening was like coming out of her
mouth like I just wanted to vomit but
don't you just have like such a pit like
you do not want them to get caught oh of
course I was watching it and I realize
like my stomach hurt and I had a pit and
I couldn't identify it I was like oh
it's the show yes it's a very anxiety
inducing show I remember that from the
first season and now it's like you've
really fallen in love with Christina
Applegate and like she's like just like
working so hard like a single mom just
like trying to keep it together and
trying to grieve and trying to keep this
secret and so you just really champion
her even though she has like a
cold-blooded killer um and you know the
whole show you just don't want her to
get caught yeah don't be suspicious
don't be suspicious can you finish it
today so we can recap tomorrow I can try
you know me I'm very busy um but I how
many episodes are there do you know like
maybe around 10 I could try
I could try okay cool um that's all she
wrote thanks all she wrote thank you
thank you guys for so much for listening
to the morning shows yeah you know she
did say it was all she called me I have
a 12 o'clock it's 12:05 okay oh my god
okay bye thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning show us the
Milani Morning Show where we go both
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
make town so it's my itunes stitcher
public radio i every to catch spots all
the places where we listen about guys -
money doesn't serve you but it goes
somewhere we are don't forget to
pre-order my comedy special available on
iTunes all the links will be available
on my Instagram and please listen to
today's episode of Maternity
available on Spotify and iTunes we love
you guys we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday
and please sign the change.org petition
you'll be able to find it in the morning
toast Instagram bye